now this one's the most fun because well
partly cause it introduces some funny
notation which will turn up more or we
do it in turquoise at the end of the
year but but yeah where my eyes playing
with me is that really just an upside
down eh
and the answer is yes it is just an
upside down hey what does it mean it's
shorthand for for all values okay so I
read that as if two polynomials of
degree n are equal for more than n
values of X then they're equal for all
values of x ah they are the same
polynomial okay now what does this mean
if we've got two polynomial so call them
MX + B of X okay and if we know for
instance that they are of degree 5 okay
if there are 5 sorry if there are 6
instances where the two polynomials are
the same for instance I find out that a
of 1 and V of 1 are the same okay
and a of I don't know minus 10 and B of
minus 10 are the same and so on and if I
can get 6 of these
okay if I can find six points where they
actually line up then I can know for
certain but don't why not for all values
that I can come up with okay or if it
was not degree 5 if whose degree 50 if I
can find 51 values where they're the
same or you get the idea okay now why is
that how can we see that it's true okay
now like why could the previous ones I'm
gonna try and draw it and see if that
song enough good explanation okay
people often get hung up on the language
of this property because it's kind of
obtuse babe but if you're putting in
terms of graphs it's really easy let's
think about to point others of degree
one okay so if I've got an X and the
events having degree one that means
they're straight lines right so suppose
they've got their equal four let's say
one value of x now I'm now going to
think of a and B in terms of what their
graphs might look like okay so if I know
a and B are equal say suppose a naught
and B naught are the same suppose they
both equal five that means there's this
point zero five that both polynomials
posters okay but if all I've got is one
value right this might be a okay and I
can have a whole bunch of beads that all
go through that point
in fact and then for the number of them
okay but if I know that both a and B go
through two points right so this is now
the more than embellish okay if you put
in two points like say here and here
right so a might go through there this
only what other not even there's only
one Paulo video that'll fit through both
those points okay you can't draw like
another one he's kind of like yeah I'm
gonna yeah and come back okay unless of
course they're degrees don't match right
in which case you've got a completely
different scenario and you can
generalize this up right suppose we did
a quadratic okay you go ahead and try
pick for yourself
three points okay say one two three okay
and draw a parabola that passes through
all the points I missed okay now if
these were three points okay there is no
other parabola that you can draw that
will fit all three of those points okay
because I've got degree two and I've got
more than two points where these two
polynomials apparently agree okay so
that means they must agree for every
other single value that's there okay